flughunde nutzen so fortbewegung einen
außergewöhnlichen bewegungsapparat der
besteht dass eine elastische haut die
sich von den fingerknochen bis zu den
zehen spannt ein deutsches
technologieunternehmen hat nun einen von
der natur inspirierten flugapparat
gebaut
diese bionische konstruktion hat eine
spannweite von zwei metern 28 bringt
aber nur 580 gramm auf die waage kleine
motoren im rumpf ermöglichen es jedem
flügel einzeln einzustellen ein größerer
motor sorgt für das flügelschlagen
selbst das macht das fluggerät sehr
wendig zwar klappen start und landungen
noch nicht ohne hilfe der konstrukteure
im flug aber ist der apparat semi
autonom in einem vorgegebenen radius
navigierte apparat mittels eine
anreihung von kameras selbstständig der
bionische flug und soll der
öffentlichkeit auf der hannover messe
ende april vorgestellt werden